E
50th SEAT IN THE U.S. SENATE,
WHAT THAT IS SO IMPORTANT.
JOIN ME NOW THE MAN FIGHTING FOR
IT, HERSCHEL WALKER TO SEE YOU
TONIGHT.
LECTURED THE PRIORITY BE FOR GOP
LEADERSHIP.
MITCH McCONNELL WANTS TO QUIT
DEAL FOR US WITH CHUCK SCHUMER
AND CONSERVATIVES ARE SAYING
THAT WAY A SECOND, YOU KNOW,
WHAT ABOUT THE PRINCIPLES WE
CARE ABOUT?
>> Herschel: I THINK THE FIRST
THING YOU SHOULD THINK ABOUT IS
WE THE PEOPLE UP.
NOT WE THE GOVERNMENT AND THAT
IS THE PROBLEM WE HAVE.
THAT IS ONE REASON I DECIDED TO
RUN.
I JUST SAW THAT THE GEORGIA
PEOPLE, THE PEOPLE OF THE UNITED
STATES WERE BEING MISTREATED.
THEY ARE SPENDING OUR MONEY.
THEY MADE US UNSAFE BY GIVING UP
OUR ENERGY AND THEY HAVE THIS
BORDER WIDE OPEN AND YOU HEAR
CHUCK SCHUMER TALKING ALREADY
ABOUT BRINGING MORE PEOPLE IN.
WE GOT TO SECURE THE SPORT AND
RIGHT NOW FENTANYL IS KILLING A
LOT OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE.
18 TO 45.
I THINK YOU NEED NEW LEADERSHIP.
WE NEED NEW LEADERSHIP ALL THE
WAY ABOUT.
THAT IS THE REASON I SAID I'M
GOING TO WASHINGTON.
I'M GOING AS A LEADER BECAUSE I
REPRESENT THE PEOPLE OF GEORGIA.
THAT IS ALL.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT ANYTHING
ELSE.
RIGHT NOW, THE PEOPLE OF GEORGIA
AND THE PEOPLE OF THE UNITED
STATES NEED REPRESENTATION IN
WASHINGTON.
>> Laura: YOUR OPPONENT WARNOCK
IS WARNING THAT SOMETHING VERY
FISHY IS A FOOT ABOUT THE
LOOMING RUNOFF.
WATCH THIS.
>> I HAVE HAD TO STAND UP TIME
AND TIME AGAIN WHEN WE HAVE SEEN
EFFORTS, THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND
AT THE STATE LEVEL.
TO MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE
TO USE THEIR VOICES.
SOME OF THE MOST SUPPRESSIVE
PARTS OF SB 202 APPLIED TO THE
RUNOFF BEING HELD IN THE STATE
OF GEORGIA RIGHT NOW.
>> Laura: HERSCHEL, ARE THESE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES?
>> Herschel: FIRST OF ALL, YOU
KNOW, HE CONTINUES TO SEPARATE
BY -- PASSED ALONG TIME AGO.
HE HAS NOT ABOUT IT.
DON'T TRIED TO CHANGE THE RULES
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE GAME.
RIGHT NOW, WE HAVE THEY WERE
NOT.
SO DO YOUR JOB.
GET OUT TO SEEK YOUR PEOPLE BUT
I'M GETTING OUT AND TRYING TO
GET THIS BECAUSE WE NEED NEW
LEADERSHIP.
HE IS REPRESENTING NO ONE BUT
JOE BIDEN.
HE WENT TO WASHINGTON.
THAT IS THE REASON I DECIDED TO
RUN.
BUT RIGHT TO HE IS TRIED TO
DIVIDED -- DIVIDE AGAIN WITH
RACISM.
FIRST OF ALL, LET'S TRY TO BRING
SOME INTEGRITY BACK TO THIS
ELECTION SYSTEM.
RIGHT NOW, I'M UPSET.
PEOPLE -- AT THIS TIME RIGHT
HERE IN THE RULES ARE ALREADY
SET.
LET'S NOT TRY TO CHANGE THEM.
WHAT WE DO IS WE DO WHAT WE HAVE
ON THE BOOKS.
YOU GO AND YOU TRY TO CHANGE IT.
DON'T THROW IT ON THE PEOPLE.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
PEOPLE.
THIS HAS TO DO WITH THE LEADERS
THAT WE PUT IN WASHINGTON AND WE
PUT A WEAK LEADER WITH -- TO DO
NOTHING BUT GO WITH JOE BIDEN
AND GO WITH WHAT THEY ARE
TELLING HIM TO DO.
HERSCHEL WALKER IS NOT THAT MAN.
THAT IS WHY I ENCOURAGE EVERYONE
ALL THE TIME, THEY ARE TRAINED
TO BUY THIS SEED.
GO TO TEAMHERSHEL.COM.
THE GEORGIA PEOPLE AND THAT IS
WHAT I'M GOING TO WASHINGTON TO
DO IS TO FIGHT F